[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we've had a massive break in
the Trump Russia Fiasco and there is
massive news to report to you today
which is that President Donald Trump is
now admitting that yeah
the purpose of his campaign meeting with
Russians that infamous day in Trump
Tower was specifically to obtain dirt on
Hillary Clinton during the campaign they
worked with Russia President Trump
admitting this in a coordinated way with
a scheduled meeting meant to get
damaging information for the purposes of
helping Donald Trump defeat Hillary
Clinton in the 2016 presidential
campaign the circle now is almost
complete and remember we go back to
where the story started there was no
Russia story there were no meetings then
the right started shifting to collusion
wouldn't actually be a crime anyway and
then in the last couple of weeks last
week I reported to you that Donald
Trump's own attorney shifted from there
was no collusion there was no
coordination to I can't find in the
Criminal Code where it even mentions
collusion that was Rudy Giuliani last
week and now for the first time we have
Donald Trump personally admitting that
this Trump Tower meeting on June 9 2016
with Russian lawyer Natalia vessel
Mnet's kaya was not about adoptions it
was to get dirt on Hillary Clinton this
is working with Russia on the
presidential campaign here's Trump's
tweet from Sunday morning which was in
response it appears to a Washington Post
article pointing out that Donald Trump
jr. might be in serious legal trouble in
this entire thing that seemed to set
Donald Trump off who said quote fake
news reporting a complete fabrication
that I am concerned
about the meeting my wonderful son
Donald had in Trump Tower this was a
meeting to get information on an
opponent totally legal and done all the
time in politics and it went nowhere I
did not know about it so Trump still
denying that he knew about it pretty
clear at this point that he did talked
about that last week claiming that it's
done all the time well not with foreign
countries we've heard from Democrats and
Republicans alike that if they were
approached by a foreign country offering
something like this
they wouldn't set up a meeting they
would call the FBI which we know the
Trump administration did not do but the
big news here it's important not to lose
the thread because Trump wants to focus
on it was legal and it was done it's
done all the time this is the first
admission from Donald Trump that the
meeting took place with the goal of
getting damaging information about his
opponent Hillary Clinton this is
something of value from a foreign power
and then of course aside from the
meeting itself this incident led to lies
from Trump about his involvement after
the fact he dictated the response letter
to this incident and the reporting of it
by the New York Times after initially
saying that he didn't dictate that
letter and the number two lies about the
subject of the meeting are now confirmed
I don't buy Donald Trump we were
initially told it was about adoptions
which in a sense it kind of was so the
Magnitsky Act is related to sanctions
and adoptions is sort of quid pro quo
for its an intimated quid pro quo that
if the hillary dirt helps trump win then
the future trump administration would
look at rewarding Russia with eased
sanctions now we know because Trump
himself said it this was about dirt on
Hillary period Trump's campaign was
offered things of value by Russia and
they accepted the offer the only step
remaining
to fully close the circle would be proof
of what Trump's former personal lawyer
alleged last week
which is that Trump knew about the
meeting in advance Trump still claims
that he didn't know about that we don't
know if we're eventually going to get
proof of that or not all of the
circumstantial and timing evidence
suggests Trump knew ahead of time
and in addition to that the question of
whether anything came of it the
narrative so far from people who have
been caught lying multiple times has
been we had the meeting we were promised
dirt on Hillary we wanted the dirt on
Hillary but we didn't ultimately get it
that's what we were told we didn't
ultimately get the dirt on Hillary
what's going to be next you know we got
some dirt and it was patriotic because
it kept Hillary out of the White House
because Russia wanted epoch make America
great again
winner Trump to win that's the only part
of the circle left to be filled
potentially hey I mean these guys Donald
Trump jr. Jared Kushner they had never
worked on a political campaign before
there was their first time and sometimes
when you dip your toe into the water of
a political campaign you accidentally
commit a few federal offenses as well
happens to anyone what are the legal
implications this could make the Donald
Trump's admission that the the point of
this meeting was to obtain dirt on his
opponent from a foreign country this
could make the meeting itself conspiracy
with a foreign country this could make
the lies about the meeting obstruction
of justice conspiracy and false
statements to the feds if false
statements to the feds were made and it
appears that they probably were at this
point given what Donald Trump jr.
reportedly told investigators and and in
a hearing rather he is not necessarily
said that to investigators and what
Trump is now admitting the meeting was
for potentially multiple federal crimes
by many people implied by this tweet by
Donald Trump but the big question
remains which is will anyone and
specifically Trump pay for it and the
answer if you don't go out in November
and vote is probably not and by the way
still some people emailing me saying
there's no Russia story but very few at
this point very few people still
emailing me saying there's no Russia
story lastly we always have to ask is
this a strategy or is this stupidity
Donald Trump saying this on Twitter it's
never clear it's a pot of possible
strategy to create chaos with the
contradictions it could be trying to get
out in front of the story before it
breaks in a more damaging way it could
be idiocy and ignorance it could be a
combination of all of these but what I
returned to every time is look at the
evolution there was no meeting there was
a meeting to discuss adoptions there was
a meeting to discuss dirt on Hillary but
we
get the dirt and the next logical step
if these are all lies is we did get dirt
but nothing illegal took place or we did
get dirt but we didn't ultimately need
it because Hillary's campaign was such a
disaster every single week we learn
about more lies that have been told to
us the Trump war on the media and a free
press continues and the theme is this
phrase the enemy of the people the enemy
of the people is the phrase that keeps
coming up about the press by Donald
Trump and by his cronies and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the White House press
secretary was asked directly a number of
times during a press briefing late last
week as the weekend was kicking off is
the press the enemy of the people as far
as she is concerned and or as far as the
Trump administration is concerned she
was asked this by the press at a press
briefing and one of the ways this is
being written up is Sarah Huckabee
Sanders refuses to deny that the press
is the enemy of the American people what
you have to understand and I'm gonna
play a clip for you here is that when
she said time and again I'm here to
represent the president's views and the
president has made his views clear it's
more than a non-denial that they see the
press as the enemy of the American
people
it is the acknowledgment that they see
the press as the enemy of the American
people she refused to say no multiple
times and said the Trump Trump is
already spoken about this it's a
slightly longer clip I'm gonna play for
you because I want you to pay attention
to the dynamics of how there are
multiple opportunities for her to just
say no no big picture I or the Trump
administration whoever she's speaking
for at the time don't see the press as
the enemy of the American people she
doesn't do that she does believe and she
is restating that the Trump
administration does believe that the
press is the enemy of the American
people let's take a look Jim on Sarah's
question from NPR she
asked you about Ivanka Trump's statement
that the press is not the enemy of the
people and she asked you whether or not
the press is the enemy of the people you
read off a laundry list of your concerns
about the press and things that you feel
like are misreported but you did not say
that the press is not the enemy of the
people and I think it would be a good
thing if you were to say right here at
this briefing that the press the people
who are gathered in this room right now
right by doing their jobs every day
asking questions of officials like the
ones you brought forward earlier or not
the enemy of the people I I think we
deserve that the president has made his
position known I also think it's ironic
I'm trying to answer your question I
politely waited and I even called on you
despite the fact that you interrupted me
why calling on your colleague I said
it's ironic and which is why I
interrupted
I'm trying if you if you finish if you
would not mind letting me have a
follow-up that would be fun but it's
ironic Jim that not only you and the
media attacked the president for his
rhetoric when they frequently lower the
level of conversation in this country
repeatedly repeatedly the media resorts
to personal attacks without any content
other than to incite anger the media has
attacked me personally on a number of
occasions including your own Network
said I should be harassed as a life
sentence that I should be choked ice
officials are not welcomed in their
place of worship and personal
information is shared on the Internet
when I was hosted by the Correspondents
Association of which almost all of you
are members of you brought a comedian
out to attack my appearance and call me
a traitor to my own gender in fact as I
know and as far as I know I'm the first
press secretary in the history of the
United States that's required Secret
Service protection the media continues
to ratchet up the verbal assault against
the president and everyone in this
administration and certainly we have a
role to play but the media has a role to
play for the discourse in this country
as well if I may follow up excuse me you
did not say in the course of those were
more
that you just made that the press is not
the enemy of the people are we to take
it from what you just said we all get
put through the wringer we all get put
in the meat grinder in this town and
you're no exception and I'm sorry that
that happened to you I wish that that
had not happened but for the sake of
this this room the people who are in
this room this democracy this country
all the people around the world are
watching what you're saying Sarah and
the White House for the United States of
America the presidency should not refer
to us as the enemy of the people his own
daughter acknowledges that and all I'm
asking you to do Sarah is to acknowledge
that right now and right here I
appreciate your passion I share it
I've addressed this question I've
addressed my personal feelings I'm here
to speak on behalf of the president he's
made his comments clear so Sarah was
that a yes or no one presses the enemy
of the American people she talks about
how she hasn't liked reports about her
and satires of her but that's not the
question the question is about the role
and the perception of the media by this
administration and if you're a defender
of the Constitution if you believe in
checks and balances the answer to this
question should be and it really has to
be a completely unequivocal and
definitive no of course the press is not
the enemy of the American people
this wasn't a vague question open to
interpretation
it's Jim Acosta from CNN who asked the
question here
he was specific she still filibustered
didn't answer and in fact she's saying
yes the press is the enemy I speak for
the president she said that's what Trump
has said and that's what the position of
the administration appears to be and
bringing up satirical pieces done about
her I guess it's either to distract her
to try to get some sympathy she might be
a more sympathetic character if she
stopped telling depraved and horrific
lies to the American people day in and
day out but it continues to amaze me how
the party that claims to be against the
safe spaces and the trigger warnings is
regularly and so easily triggered and
what's dangerous and vile about this
position is that it is even worse than
what we've seen from some of the worst
Republicans I don't romanticize Bush you
know that rap but even Bush would say
directly when he had big
flicks with individual media outlets a
free press is necessary and healthy to
democracy it's such a simple thing to
say if you believe in it and they're
just not saying it because they don't
believe in it we also know that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders calling card is off you
see a Shinto yeah so she could have
walked that tightrope and done it a
little bit better right between
appeasing President Trump and also
reassuring the importance of a free
press like she could have said that most
outlets are totally fine but there are
some liberal reporters out there doing a
horrible job and named them for example
like she could have young both things
she could have played both sides there
like she normally does she decided not
to go with I don't know if calling out
specific reporters would be walking the
tightrope necessarily but the big
picture is creeping authoritarianism and
when it's all said and done either in
2020 or in 2024 I hope that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is remembered for what
she's become which is one of the most
disgusting participants in this aberrant
administration and aberrant not on
policy but in terms of it's just
fundamental and basic disrespect for the
base tenets of the foundation of the
United States of America send me your
thoughts if you're as concerned as I am
about the battle against the press I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Michael Mayer Michael Mayer has been
a recent addition to the membership
roles of the David Pakman show were
mostly funded by members like Michael
Mayer but I don't want to forget our
long term sustaining members and today's
longtime member of the day is Matt
Houser
Matt Hauser's been with us about five
and a half years going on six years
Michael Matt thank you joined them both
at WWJ Ann pakman.com memberships are
available at a 40% discount if you so
choose by using the coupon code vote
soon 18 I have potentially good news for
you except that it's total BS and what I
mean is that there was a report which if
true would be really great news which is
that the NRA the National Rifle
Association the biggest gun lobby in the
United States they are claiming to have
such deep financial trouble that they
may be unable to continue existing which
would be lovely news except it is very
clearly an attempt to garner more
support and to push back against what
they feel is an unfair case being made
against an insurance program of theirs
by the New York by New York State and
all of this information came from a
document that the NRA filed which
Rolling Stone obtained and what the NRA
is filing says is that because of a
lawsuit that is being brought against
them by New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
and New York state financial regulators
they have become victims of a black
listing campaign by the state and have
suffered tens of millions of dollars in
damages and what they claim is they
can't access basic financial services
that they need in order to operate that
they're facing quote irrecoverable loss
and irreparable farm harm they say that
they've lost insurance cover
that they need for day-to-day operations
that some of their physical offices are
at risk that their video streaming
service and magazine may have to shut
down this is all fantastic I can't
imagine better news here but I am very
clear that these claims are being
completely exaggerated since they are
being made in a filing against New York
State they say that they've been
unfairly targeted by state regulators
over what the state claims is the
illegal sale of NRA branded insurance
for gun owners the NRA was offering this
insurance called carry guard and what
carry guard would do is if you are a gun
owner and member of the NRA and you
legally fire a gun and as a result of
legally firing that gun you incur legal
expenses carry guard NRA insurance will
reimburse you for those legal expenses
lovely little program that they have
isn't it so I think that if true this
would be great news I want the NRA to
disappear they exist to increase gun
sales they exist to make people afraid
of the world so that they go out and
they buy guns and now we are learning
that they also existed during the 2016
campaign to work as a conduit between
Russia and the Trump campaign funneling
tons of foreign money to Donald Trump
but do I believe even for a second that
the NRA is on the verge of disappearing
obviously not obviously not the NRA is
very clearly exaggerating the supposedly
dire state of their financial position
they're misrepresenting their financial
situation to get donations to turn
people against the state of New York
this is a stunningly well-funded
organization and I don't believe it at
all that they are at risk yeah I too
think it's a fund raising plea
especially because Republicans are in
control of the government now and what
helps the NRA is making the case that
the government is going to take away
your guns and they especially make that
case after like a mass shooting sure
because Republicans are in charge of
everything they can't effectively
communicate that case in the same way
that gun manufacturers have been
suffering when it comes to gun sales
partially because you don't have a
Democrat in the White
house that the NRA is saying he's about
to take your guns maybe the NRA has been
suffering mildly when it comes to
membership and so on and so forth but
they've got as we learned foreign money
coming in they've got domestic money
coming in and this is all a ploy to
suggest that the New York State lawsuit
against them is unfair interference in
what the NRA does but this is a PR
campaign it's a bottom line that's what
it is the NRA is not a responsible
organization it's a political
organization it's a business
organization that works exclusively for
gun manufacturers to sell more guns in
more places and there's been a big
campaign on Twitter started to send the
NRA thoughts and prayers which of course
is a reference to how the NRA always
will send thoughts and prayers after
shootings which of course do nothing and
I think it's equally likely that
thoughts and prayers on Twitter won't do
anything for the NRA suppose it
fundraising woes which I would argue
barely barely exists so don't fall for
this although it would be something to
rejoice about if indeed the NRA went out
of business they're not going out of
business and this is just an attempt to
get more money out of people last week
when I was in New Orleans Louisiana for
Netroots nation I reported to you that
the online streaming service Spotify
removed some episodes of Alex Jones
podcasts for violations of their
Community Guidelines content guidelines
in terms of service we also reported
that Facebook and YouTube have sort of
sporadically been pulling some
individual pieces of Alex Jones content
off the air and then this morning I woke
up to the news that Apple has made the
decision to remove all Alex Jones and
Infowars content from iTunes which is of
course one of the biggest audio
streaming and podcasting services in the
world the entire library is being
removed and piggybacking on this we also
learned this morning that Spotify and
Facebook will be removing even more Alex
Jones content from their libraries so
let's go through this piece by piece
question one was anything of value lost
is anything of value lost by the removal
of Alex Jones content from different
places on the Internet the answer is and
edek no no absolutely not is this
censorship of Alex Jones well let's
think about that he can still produce
the show right so not being on iTunes
has no impact on whether he can get up
put his pants on one leg at a time or
maybe jumping into both legs at once I
wouldn't presume to know how Alex Jones
puts his pants on going on wearing pants
maybe he's not even asked there you
don't see even below the desk go into
his studio and do his show no he can
still produce the show he can distribute
it on his own servers if he wants I
don't know that that's something that he
does and he can put the content anyplace
that will have him now do I understand
why he would call it censorship the
answer is yes would I be saying the same
things if iTunes banned the David Pakman
show
I probably would but what we have to
think about here is is there a double
standard and on the one hand claiming to
be a free market libertarian minded
individual who wants businesses to have
the opportunity and the right and the
the ability to make decisions that they
want to make about their platform which
they built with their money right
ultimately that's what Apple did with
iTunes or do we say that they should be
forced to host Alex Jones's content and
part of the problem with Jones
specifically is that he's a conspiracy
theorist who partially makes money
saying claiming that everybody wants to
suppress his speech because they don't
want the ultimate truths he's telling to
get out there when iTunes then pulls him
off I think it definitely bolsters that
narrative with his audience of course
you've got a conspiracy theorist their
content gets singled out for removal
that becomes evidence of the conspiracy
to suppress the dangerous truths that
Alex Jones is willing to tell the
reality is the content isn't being
pulled off iTunes or wherever because
it's conspiratorial it's being removed
because it's against Apple's hate-speech
guidelines Facebook's explanation is
similar not conspiracies but glorifying
violence using the humanizing language
to refer to people who are transgender
Muslim and immigrants Spotify now
removing all Alex Jones content
it's because he is expressly and
principally promoting advocating or
inciting hatred or violence against the
group or individual based on
characteristics so the question for me
is more about what is legally okay for
these companies to do I don't think
anyone would argue that any of these
companies are doing anything that is
sort of against the law or certainly not
a violation of the First Amendment
because we're not talking about the
government and then we can start
thinking about is there anything that
makes content publishing platforms
different right could you say that
because Spotify and Facebook and YouTube
have massive curation power that it's a
form of suppressing speech I don't know
that's certainly the case that the
defenders of Alex Jones are going to
make I actually don't know how it took
this long for Jones to become a
liability on these platforms right I
mean the Sandy Hook truth or stuff Pizza
gage only now the platforms are saying
we're gonna pull them off I guess it's
probably partially because of public
outcry yeah and I mean he's been saying
crazy stuff for a long time but it's
getting worse and worse I feel like
after Sandy Hook would be the time to do
it right I was thinking of an analogy to
what Alex Jones has been doing and I
thought let's say I want to write a book
right and I've mentioned I've thought
about writing a book I've talked to
literary agents I would need a publisher
for the book or I can choose to self
publish which would be sort of like Alex
Jones saying well I'm gonna put the
content on my own servers so nobody can
pull it off of there if I bring the book
to 50 publishers and they all say no we
don't want to publish it are my ideas
being suppressed do I have any right to
be published by a publisher who
publishes other political books I think
the answer is obviously no now you might
hear me make that analogy and say David
that's different a book publisher makes
individual deals with writers Spotify
Facebook YouTube whoever these are
platforms where the default is anybody
can make an account and upload stuff so
with publishing of a book it's a
decision decision to publish that the
business makes with Facebook and YouTube
and Spotify and iTunes they're making
the decision to say we're going to
remove Alex Jones Khan
and that's a different situation I think
it's a distinction without a relevant
difference
it was Rand Paul who said something
about single-payer health care would
make doctors slaves or something like
that right because they would have to
work because they would have to cover
everyone everybody yeah they didn't have
to be doctors if they don't want to they
can choose another job so then the
analogy from what rand paul said here is
are you enslaving itunes if you force
them to host alex jones is content you
can't really make the argument rand paul
made without applying the same logic to
Spotify or iTunes or Facebook and also
interesting of course is that the same
people who simultaneously argue
businesses should be able to do whatever
they want as long as it's not illegal
they should be able to you know it
should be legal to discriminate against
people on the basis of their sexual
orientation real or perceived for
example but they should be forced to
host Alex Jones content that doesn't
really make sense to me they should be
able to deny a gay person service but
you're forced to publish Alex Jones as
pizza gate rantings and Sandy Hook
truther ISM I would actually make the
case that since being gay isn't a choice
but being of violence inciting
conspiracy theorist is business should
be allowed to discriminate against
violence inciting conspiracy theorists
way before they should be allowed to
discriminate against gay people but
that's I think going a little bit deeper
than maybe the Alex the specifics of the
Alex Jones situation warrant if you
disagree with me and I know from the
messages I was getting on Twitter
earlier today there are people who
believe I am being hypocritical here but
if it was me being targeted that I would
have a different view that may be
because I would have a very emotional
response but if I'm violating Terms of
Service aren't I just violating Terms of
Service if you disagree with me let me
know this is also being discussed on the
David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t discuss it there we will take a
quick break and
with plenty more right after this the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to be joined today by Billy
Delancey who's the co-founder and CEO of
lobbyists for good which is a
crowdfunding platform that enables
everyday people to hire professional
lobbyists so Billy that this is sort of
there's this debate in politics about
inside outside strategies do you work
within a system to your advantage or do
you try to change the system if you
believe that the system is fundamentally
broken corrupt or otherwise not not
working properly when it comes to
lobbying this is I think you would agree
an extraordinarily corrosive element of
American politics but it is here and it
appears to be here to stay is your
argument on that basis let's see if we
can use it to do some good
that's exactly it David thanks for
having me on the program lobbying isn't
going to go away even if we were to pass
a law that banned lobbying having people
not allowed to lobby that it would be
guaranteed to be thrown out because of
the First Amendment there's a line that
says that everybody has the right to
petition the government for redress of
grievances so that's exactly right wait
how you said it why don't we use the
tools available to change the system and
get every day people to have a stronger
voice in government how does the
platform work is it sort of like a
Kickstarter for lobbying that's exactly
what it is and we actually use that
description when when describing it to
people individuals every day American
citizens or green card holders can go
onto our platform and submit ideas or
campaigns around issues that they care
about and if the individual can
gain raises $5,000 within a hundred days
we will go ahead and find a lobbyist
here in DC to advocate for their cause
on Capitol Hill
now how much professional lobbying this
five grand get you because it feels like
it might get you you know a paragraph
email or something like that yeah not
much the reason we have the $5,000 and
most people that's the first thing they
point out too we had we had it higher
originally but because we're a new
organization because we don't have a
large email list we wanted the barrier
of entry to be a little bit lower so we
have $5,000 right now about 14 hours of
lobbying and the things that we're gonna
do a lot of the backend research so when
you come up when you start a lobbying
campaign and there's a lot of work
around strategy researching the issue
identifying targets on the hill we're
gonna do a lot of that so that the
people that we hire will be able to go
directly to the hill and use that that
time to meet one-on-one with legislators
and their staff so let's think through
sort of in total when we think about the
amount of money that might be raised on
your platform for individual lobbying
efforts hypothetically if all of that
money were pooled together and used to
try to change the system of lobbying and
campaign finance that we have might it
have a bigger impact it's an interesting
question but I think we might be
thinking a little bit too big I started
the platform to help people there's a
woman who started a campaign who's a
female veteran and there's a bill in in
Congress that would help force the VA to
look after female veterans because it's
just when such a male-dominated system
so that type of effort could pass a bill
like that 5,000 10,000 because a has
bipartisan support and just needs a push
to the end we lobby for the Institute of
Peace which is an organization that
tries to mitigate unless environment
conflicts around the world and we spent
about 40 hours and we were able to
increase their budget by three million
dollars so do I think
this is a platform that's gonna change
our democracy and fix every problem that
we have I don't know I hope it's a
useful tool but it's one of many many
things that need to happen but I think
that we're gonna be very successful by
helping these these issues and these
these people who don't know where to
even begin or who call their legislator
convince their legislator but need to
reach all 534 other senators in Congress
well I should say 532 if they get there
both senators and congressmen so we're
trying to focus more on just getting
that individual person a stronger voice
whether or not we can be used as a tool
to fix all that ills American democracy
I'm not convinced yet but I hope that we
can be part of the solution can you talk
a little bit about how the lobbying
process works I mean I think people
generally have an understanding that for
example like a large corporate Lobby
gets like the National the NCTA which
lobbies on the behalf of telecom and
cable providers those cable providers
and big companies give NCTA a bunch of
money and then NCTA goes and does what
like what is the actual nuts and bolts
of the lobbying process a lot of it's
just building relationships and and
using those relationships to get 30
minutes of the staffers time
that's an interesting example about the
telecom because they have hundreds and
hundreds of lobbyists working for them
every day and most of those lobbyists
are connected whether they worked on the
hill before or whether or not they're
former members of Congress themselves
but an organization like that uses those
relationships and uses the money that
they give to political candidates to get
the access to get that staffers 20
minutes at the right time when the bill
that they're working on is at the right
moment when they need a favor or they
need an action on it and it really is
about that relationship building I'll
give a story about our experience in
lobbying we identified the Institute of
Peace as an organization they
was important and was completely ignored
by both Democrats and Republicans and so
what we did is we hired a lobbyist a
Republican who had worked with a lot of
people in foreign aid and foreign
affairs and all we did and we didn't
give a dime to any political candidates
we didn't you know walk into Congress
with a bag of money we emailed him and
he used a lot of his personal
connections from when he worked on the
hill and we just asked for 30 minutes of
people's time and we went in and we went
in with a good argument and we said you
know this is why the Institute of Peace
needs to be funded at a higher level the
war in Iraq is winding down and when it
does there gonna be a lot of conflicts
between the groups that came together to
fight Isis or ISIL and we need somebody
to be there to talk to those groups and
have a peace mediation conflict
resolution and it worked and we were
able to get three million dollars pretty
much on a three thousand dollar effort
so that they could increase the programs
that they were doing in Iraq and
Afghanistan so to answer your question
if sorry if I was long-winded
it's about accessing the people who need
to you need to reach and it's about
going in with a good argument and then
having an appropriate follow-up for when
the bill that you're concerned about is
in the legislative process to reach out
to those people and say listen this is
how I want you to vote this is I need
you to co-sponsor and kind of that's how
you can work the system so 3,000 and
lobbying spend for three million in
funds seems like is that a ten ten
thousand percent return I'm not sure I
didn't exactly run the numbers but it
seems like it might be a ten thousand
percent return do you have data about
what the return is on lobbying
investment either across the entire
lobbying space within particular
industries or you know any data you
might have about that it's all it's not
our data but it's the sunlight
foundation did a study and they found
and I'll give three examples when oil
companies lobby for a subsidy that would
benefit them they found a 5,000 percent
turn on their investment when
corporations banded together and lobbied
for a tax holiday a corporate tax
holiday and I think the year was 2003
2004 they found a 22,000 percent return
on their investment and when
pharmaceutical companies lobbied for the
provision in Medicare where they
couldn't compete the drug prices and I'm
a little iffy on exactly what they lobby
for but it was about you know competing
for drug prices 76,000 percent return on
their investment and so we're hoping
that we can have that kind of our ally
for the people and I'll just really
quick I used to work in foreign affairs
foreign aid and we lobbied for an
increased budget in foreign aid and you
know I gave $20 to Save the Children a
wonderful organization that does a lot
of good work around the world and here
in the US and then when we lobbied for
them we were able to get bumps of two
million four million so individuals can
do a great service by donating but a lot
of the change really does come from
government whether it's a policy whether
it's funding the return on investment in
the lobbying of lobbyists is staggering
how does your organization determine
what a good project is in other words
people could disagree about what
priorities should be or about what
really deserves attention or or lobbying
funds spent on it so what what sort of
the infrastructure to determine what is
good enough well that's a great question
and in one way we struggled with we
don't want to drive policy we want to be
a tool a resource to connect people
outside of the Beltway to be people who
have influence in government so that
they can have a stronger voice and so
what we decided to do is just have a set
of founding principles that every
lobbying campaign must meet and if it
meets those founding principles we will
host it on a platform even if it's
something that we don't necessarily
support a hundred percent but everything
within those founding principles will
will be hosted on a platform and it's
pretty simple it's it has to be for the
common good and that means that it can't
benefit
in industry it can't benefit a group of
people specifically has to benefit
everybody as a whole it has to be driven
by the second one is it has to be driven
by the people so a CEO of a telecom
communications can't submit a campaign
to our platform and an advocate for
defeating net neutrality so it has to be
citizens driven the other things that
are required number three is that it has
to be it have a chance of bipartisanship
so anything super far left super far
right where no buddy on the other party
is gonna we call it dead on arrival in
hill
we won't host campaigns like that and
that kind of weeds out any of these
extreme policies extreme politics the ID
the ideological extremes that could be
on our platform so we have that as a
protector and then the other thing the
last thing is that it needs to be
underrepresented there's a lot of good
nonprofits out there there's a lot of
great organizations that lobby for some
great causes and if their money is if
people's money is gonna be better
donated to that organization will
instruct the person to fundraise for
that organization but what we found is
even if there is a great nonprofit
that's has you know three four five
lobbyists they're going against 50 60 70
better paid lobbyists from the corporate
or from the special interest group that
opposes so we haven't used that
underrepresented one yet but we do feel
that we want to be kind of the voice for
the voiceless so those are important
super super interesting and I encourage
people to check out the lobbyists for
good website we've been speaking with
Billy Delancey who's the co-founder and
CEO of lobbyist for good a Billy will be
following it and I look forward to
seeing the success of future campaigns
I appreciate it Dave thanks so much for
having me on the David Pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
okay so if you've been watching the
program for a while if you listen to the
show you know that I have no delusions
about blue states or liberal cities or
just all Democrats or whatever being
clean of racism so to speak to differing
degrees even our bluest cities and most
progressive institutions and most
self-described liberal people still
harbor racist prejudice and beliefs and
I've done interviews about the
significant racism that existed
historically
in our broadcast city of Boston in New
York City where I used to live I've
talked about how segregated these cities
still are to this day and even on
college campuses liberal college
campuses in liberal cities in blue
states there is still plenty of racism
and I have a story for you today from
the home town of the David Pakman show
Northampton Massachusetts where we
started and specifically from Smith
College which is an extremely liberal
College where I have both family and
friends that work as faculty and staff
and the story has gone completely
national and the story is that of a
black student who was eating lunch in a
common room and she had the police
called on her by a Smith College
employee because she looked reportedly
out of place I'm talking about
uma knut a I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly who's a sophomore at Smith
College and teaches chemistry to high
schoolers over the summer she was
reading and eating lunch in the Tyler
house dorms dining hall I've been in the
Tyler house many times a completely
normal place where people exist in the
world like you would expect on any
college campus and sometimes consume
food for the purposes of synthesizing it
into nutrients to Harbor the power of
life right completely normal activity
that we all participate in and next
thing you know a police officer is
walking in with a Smith College employee
and they tell her they're wondering why
she's there police told her that an
employee had called them about what was
initially described as a suspicious
black man of course she's a woman and
now the college has both apologized to
her and has suspended or put on leave
pending an investigation the employee
who made the call who as far as I saw a
couple hours ago still has not been
identified publicly and it's also not
clear exactly what was suspicious about
eating lunch officer the food appeared
to be extremely spicy and well dressed
please please hurry up
the student says she did nothing wrong
she wasn't making noise she wasn't
bothering anyone she was just black as
she describes it so to be clear we're
not talking here about institutional
racism it's not a lesson about Smith
College being liberal and for black
lives matter and whatever else but still
being racist as an institution as far as
we know right now barring the the news
that this was related to some kind of
policy this was just one employee but
it's just another reminder that there's
racism everywhere even in blue states
even in blue cities even at liberal
progressive colleges this individual
could be anybody they could have any
political beliefs I have no idea since
we don't know exactly who it is right
now but the other really odd thing is
that to call the police about this
instead of just walking up to the person
and saying hey who are you it implies
either that the Smith employee was
really genuinely intimidated by this
woman which okay would be a little odd
or that they were cowards and that they
said I'm gonna try to get somebody else
to do the dirty work that I need done
but even that element of it doesn't make
any sense yeah I think all the blame
goes to the employee you can't really
even blame the police officer
necessarily because they're responding
to a call they got to investigate I
would just hope that at the end of the
conversation there the police officer
would instruct the employee to
investigate a little bit on their own or
at least not make such an impulsive
decision there is one other possibility
which is as I mentioned the report was
allegedly about a suspicious black male
is it possible that the person that the
police ended up speaking to who was this
woman was not the person about whom the
report was originally filed like it's
such a basic question and I've not seen
follow up on that I don't know like was
this even the person who the report was
about I don't know but the impact so far
is that
the student has been significantly
traumatized by this understandably the
employing question has been placed on
leave and as always we get into can we
really attribute this to personal racism
was the individual who called the police
personally racist I don't know the
underlying circumstances are that an
employee at a prestigious expensive
private school thought that a black
student eating lunch looked out of place
was it their clothing that made them
look out of place was it the food that
they had was it their race I don't know
that we can really know for sure we
always hear the rights say you can't
know a hundred percent what's in
someone's head but I think it's
perfectly reasonable to talk about race
as a factor here well yeah I mean
usually there's no control group to
compare it to when we hear about these
stories it's one incident yeah because
it's just one incident but there are
white students I'm sure eating lunch in
that common Hall every single day and I
take it that they're not getting the
police called on them I've not heard
about any such incidents that's a good
question though and it's important you
know I think at the at the end of the
day what's important is don't allow the
right to shut down an exploration of
race as a motivating factor because the
right is very quick to say you can't
accuse people of racism unless you know
it definitively there could have been
other reasons why the police were called
on this particular individual and to
attribute racism to someone when you're
not a hundred and ten percent sure that
that's what it is that's wrong okay that
may be but they can't say that you can't
talk about race as a factor here to
attribute specific we don't even know
who the person was but don't allow the
topic of race to be suppressed by those
individuals yeah the worst thing in the
world is to be accused of being racist
so says the right wing yes that's a
common refrain that we hear from them
we'll see ultimately what else we learn
about the circumstances underlying this
we have been covering the hit that
tourism in the United States has taken
under Donald Trump and I was thinking to
myself if world tourism were down and US
tourism were also down it might have
nothing to do with Donald Trump right we
can't say if tourism is down everywhere
among the United States or including the
United States that it's because of Don
Trump but we now have a new report
showing that actually worldwide in the
developed world there has been a boom in
travel and yet the United States and one
other country turkey in what's
considered the developed world have seen
a decrease in travel and it's becoming
increasingly clear that many elements of
Donald Trump being president of the
United States are really hurting the
hospitality industry big time partially
because people are saying if Trump's
president I don't want to go to the
United States the US Travel Association
has confirmed that not only has travel
been down under Donald Trump to the
United States they project that in 2018
it's going to end up down even more and
when you look at the numbers in terms of
percentages they're not obviously huge
US tourism was twelve point nine percent
of world tourism when Trump took over
the presidency it was down to twelve
percent last year it's down to eleven
point seven percent in 2018 but what you
have to consider is given the size of
this pie of worldwide tourism or tourism
to develop nations zero point five
percent represents a massive amount of
money and a huge number of tourism
dollars and a significant number of
tourism and hospitality hospitality
related jobs and what every indication
points to are a few different factors
number one the travel ban itself is
keeping some people out of the country
right like some people can't come to the
United States because of the travel ban
the existence of the travel ban is
making more people choose not to come to
the United States Trump's policy on
climate change is keeping people in some
parts of the world out of the United
States Trump's attacks on other
countries including some of our allies
are keeping other people from traveling
to the United States and meanwhile this
is not a worldwide phenomenon tourism is
up in the entire developed world again
except in the United States and in
Turkey Spain Australia Canada on and on
and on significant increases in tourism
and at the bottom the United States down
six percent overall and turkey down six
point seven percent overall turkey
partially is because a number of
countries have travel warnings about the
safety of going to that country so when
you look at that and you say here
the list of developed countries for the
purposes of this study turkey has
significant security issues that
countries are warning people about
against traveling there you see that it
is indeed Donald Trump that is a
disaster for the American tourism
industry and this is an example of
something that takes a while to fix if
Trump left office tomorrow you don't
immediately get tourism back we've seen
graduate students decrease applications
to come to graduate school in the United
States these are processes planning a
trip sometimes months ahead of time
applying to and moving to another
country to go to school these things
take a while and it's going to be a
while even after Donald Trump leaves
office for this to reverse course and I
don't think they would even care right
Republicans by and large wouldn't care
because if you're visiting the US from a
foreign country chances are you going to
the cities right maybe you're going to
New York City or maybe you go into like
Hawaii which is another blue area so
that doesn't that's not their voter base
they wouldn't care so much maybe they
say we don't really want people from
other countries coming here I mean
Sweden and Norway would be fine of
course but we don't necessarily want
these individuals in the country they
could overstay visas they might be the
same types of people that we're trying
to deport on a regular basis and even
though this is bad for our economy
it's sort of is the logical conclusion
for this insular anti-immigrant
xenophobic jingoistic agenda that we've
been covering on the behalf of the Trump
administration for nearly two years now
and if the idea was stop people from
wanting to come to the United States at
least when it comes to people coming for
tourism it actually seems to be working
although I don't know whether that's
actually what the Republicans in
Congress in the Senate and in the Oval
Office intended last week I told you
that breastfeeding in public had been
legally affirmed in 50 states with I
think was Idaho and Utah which were the
holdovers that are the holdbacks that
hadn't yet done that one caller known to
us as the Texas troll is not at all
pleased with the idea of me affirming
public breastfeeding take a listen to
this David I really don't think it's too
much to ask for women just to go to the
bathroom to breastfeed their children it
just doesn't really make much sense to
me just you know go into a private place
to do it
I mean do you really think it should be
legal for a woman just to take her shirt
off on an airplane and start
breastfeeding I mean with her Tatas
hanging all over the place you really
think that's okay really have some
decency man that's disgusting
yeah um first of all I mean just as a
purely practical matter have you ever
seen a breastfeeding woman just take off
her top when when she's going to
breastfeed I've actually never seen ever
happen to be no no that that's just not
the way it works and number two you're
you're saying it should be against the
law to do that that how is that even
remotely logical I mean can't you just
look away - I understand how it could
maybe make you uncomfortable like if
you're sitting next to a woman on a
plane who's breastfeeding but just deal
with it right look away do something
else right how is this worthy of even a
call to a program to say that it's
disgusting that this really seems like a
person who has bigger issues I would
imagine than somebody breastfeeding in
public and it this is exactly what I'm
talking about even though to so many of
us it's obvious that this should not be
a legal issue I've got people calling in
and saying David how dare you think it's
legal for a woman to breastfeed in
public and expose a breast how how on
earth would I determine that it should
be illegal that's what seems actually
actually crazy or even nipple man free
absolutely we've got a great bonus show
for you today become a member at WWE
pakman.com to instantly access the bonus
show you can also get accessed by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]